last question today is from Ava who says
what political issue do your parents
disagree with you most on this is tough
for me because I agree with my parents
on most political issues I mean I think
if I had to say anything I would say
with my dad he's less fully come around
on all aspects of transgenderism I would
say supports transgender rights could
not care less what bathroom people use
etc but he has not fully come around on
some of the more proactive measures that
some schools are taking for example to
sort of go around the room and discuss
what gender pronouns you want to use he
thinks that being that proactive is a
little too much and I don't know I don't
have a strong position on that one way
or the other I think maybe forcing
everybody to identify gender pronouns
maybe actually is a bit much so maybe
I'm not that far off with my dad on that
but maybe maybe there there's a little
bit of disagreement as far as with my
mom goes um I I don't know I'm pretty
spot on politically with my mom yeah
everyone knows I think at this point
that there are a lot of conservatives in
my family yeah and we all have
disagreements on these big overarching
issues so for example wealth inequality
okay when you point out to them that
eight people on earth have more than the
combined wealth of the bottom half of
the planet they'll say something like
well you know I'm sure they do a lot of
charitable work so it's okay to give a
lot of charity what about at micro
issues are there ever micro issues like
about a specific travel ban or something
like that
it always devolves into the macro so
we're talking about torture for example
yeah and they'll respond by saying you
know 9/11 though big attack people had
to jump out of the buildings one of the
worst travesties in American history and
you can even say you know people who
have been tortured Republicans even like
John McCain are against it yeah they
realize that it's counterproductive it
doesn't get through to them is it easier
to disagree on a micro issue or on a
macro issue because it feels like on a
micro issue it's much more difficult to
sort of quote agree to disagree which I
hate anyway but on a macro issue you're
talking about one's broader personal
philosophy yeah
strikes me that it's easier to disagree
about macro issues I think it's a lot
easier to get to a solution when it
to these micro issues or just to stay on
topic because once you get into the
macro there's so many things you can go
off of yeah just the conversation just
gets bastardized it's a good thing we
have Pat here because I don't really
have a good answer to this one I mean I
real I'm trying to think more of issues
where I'm more at odds with my parents
on politics and I just am really
struggling to to think of what else
there is I think there's always going to
be that generational divide you know
yeah parents in the 60s had the same
thing with their kids and it's going to
continue I mean you can look back in
history and find people saying that
their kids are too lazy and this was
1,000 or 2,000 years ago and that's what
everybody today people are saying the
same thing about Millennials of course a
group that I am squarely a member of as
we've determined a number of times on
the program okay that does it for today
great bonus show coming up david
pakman.com slash membership get on the
bonus show it's great